bûcher pour garantir l'avenir sécurisé
et stable de toute l'humanité
la crise a montré l'interdépendance de
tous les états sans aucune exception
dans tous les domaines de la vie sociale
la russie porte l'attention sur le
caractère transfrontalier des menaces y
compris la non prolifération des armes
de destruction massive
le lac au trafic et j'en passe la
pandémie que l'humanité traverse demande
notre réponse à ces défis et c'est
d'autant plus important
l'événement de cette année ont montré
que personne ne peut être à l'abri de
ces dangers cette infection a affecté
chacun sait pourquoi il faut surmonter
les conséquences ensemble en abandonnant
les différences structurelles
malheureusement ce mal n'a pas effacé et
les différences crise ont fait leur
apparition et les crises que nous avons
observés dans le passé dans un nombre de
pays
il ya eu une tension de chercher les
fautifs ailleurs et non pas à
l'intérieur il y à des tentatives de
certains c'est un de utiliser cette
situation pour réaliser le rêve
d'intérêt et pour un combattre leur
rencontre en géopolitique
il ya une pratique des sanctions
unilatérales illégitime qui sape la
priorité des bases des nations unies
nous avons porté à maintes reprises sur
l'attention sur la nécessité de
supprimer les sanctions qui le frappent
les couches de populations les plus
vulnérables qui n'ont plus accès aux
médicaments par exemple
le secrétaire général des nations unies
a fait cet appel et nous soutenons cette
initiative du monsieur le secrétaire
général lors du sommet du groupe des 20
le président poutine a proposé la
création des couloirs verts mais
malheureusement les états qui utilisent
cet outil de sanctions restent sourds
quant à nos arguments et nous déplorons
que cela porte le préjudice aux
nécessités des simples gens dans tous
les coins de la planète je suis certain
que les efforts internationaux pour
surmonter cette crise doivent être
coordonnés avec le rôle central des
nations unies cette organisation
internationale reste un outil est une
plate forme universelle pour le dialogue
et pour la mise au point de
l'architecturé tables internationales
cela dit pour nous il est très injuste
is de critiquer les nations unies la
structure spécialisée
cela concerne par exemple l'organisation
mondiale de santé puisque selon le grand
nombre des pays à toutes les étapes de
cette crise le ms a fait preuve du
professionnalisme et a pris des mesures
opportunes en contact avec tous les pays
membres est certainement le potentiel de
ce système international de santé
nécessite d'être consolidée et la russie
a fait sa contribution pour ce que parce
que la russie a été la première à mettre
enfin le vaccin nous réaffirmons notre
disponibilité de coopérer avec toutes
les organisations internationales
avant-hier à cette tribune des nations
unies le président poutine a proposé le
vaccin gratuit à tout personnel des
nations unies c'est notre réponse à la
demande de
des nations unies et bien sûr la russie
n'est pas restée sourde à ces demandes
président russe a proposé également
d'organiser une visioconférence et tous
les pays qui mènent maintenant la
l'élaboration de ce vaccin
cette pandémie est devenu en fait un
cygne noir un qui nous a mis devant un
choix accusé les uns contre les autres
dans ce mal au bien être ensemble ce
choix est évident mais cette voie la
deuxième voie nécessite une volonté et
la mentalité stratégique il faut
commencer par un dialogue honnête entre
les membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité conformément à la charte des
nations unies son responsable pour la
stabilité et la paix dans le monde et
c'est pourquoi la russie a proposé de
convoquer le sommet mais des pays
membres ce qui a été mentionné par le
président russe avant-hier ce dialogue
direct des leaders des cinq pays sur les
voies de solution des problèmes clés de
l'humanité serait une démarche très
importante pour rétablir une stabilité
de global stratégique dans cette période
post pandémique
nous sommes certains que dès que la
possibilité nos le la situation ne le
permettent il faut le faire il faut
utiliser également d'autres formats de
contact sur le pied d'égalité qualité de
consensus et de coopération par exemple
l'interaction au sein du groupe des
vingt au sein du brics est de location
de coopération de shanghai nous sommes
certains que ce sont les structures qui
permettent de réagir de façon souple us
que l' architecture mondiale maintenant
est très
compliqué conseil de sécurité serait
présidée par la fédération de russie et
nous ferons tout notre possible pour que
cet organisme essentiel des nations
unies pour l'éco père est rentré plus
tôt les pays à la base du droit
international et à base des principes et
des objectifs de la charte ou de l'onu
je voudrais remercier pour cette
initiative
monsieur le secrétaire général merci
beaucoup pour votre attention